hi Samuel Leeds here and on this video I
wanted to share with you the five top
things that I learned from meeting with
Arnold Schwarzenegger it's gonna be
pretty epic so stay tuned lesson 1 take
what you do seriously
but don't take yourself seriously the
first thing that I learned from Arnold
Schwarzenegger was that he is a
light-hearted fun guy yes is the
Governor of California and he's active
in loads of successful movies and he's a
bodybuilder but above all that he's just
a human being that doesn't take himself
too seriously so if you're getting
really worked up in whatever you're
doing and you're getting really serious
just remember to be successful does not
mean that you have to be serious lesson
two success is a habit it's a habit it's
a lifestyle choice it's very easy to
think that this is what I want to get to
in our financial goals our health goals
whatever it cause it might be and we
need to work really really really really
hard then finally we get there and it ah
we've arrived but that's not how it is
you know the things that you need to do
to become successful need to become part
of your a bitchin life style so when I
met up with Arnold Schwarzenegger for
dinner he bent to the gym that day twice
twice he's now over 70 years old he
didn't work out really really really
hard in the gym become mr. universe and
then ha that's not how it works so the
things that you need to need to become
successful make them a habit make them a
lifestyle choice lesson 3 how you do
anything is how you do everything what
do I mean by that well Arnold
Schwarzenegger something I noticed was
he had a really good body
he was really successful in business
he's a Hollywood actor he's influential
in politics he seems to be everything he
touches turns to gold
why is that well that's because in life
how you do anything is how you do
everything sometimes it's easy to think
we need to choose what do we have doing
one
good relationships or do we what loss of
money or do we want good health which
one are we gonna prioritize but it's not
like that at all in life if you're
disciplined in one area you'll be
disciplined and successful in all the
areas so sooner that I personally really
took away from me an Arnold
Schwarzenegger was the health side of
things because I've certainly neglected
my health over the last few years so
I've become a millionaire and I've got
really good marriage and really good
relationships really good socialize but
I'm a bit fat and I've made excuses for
that because I was successful in other
areas but on sports thing a really
challenged me to think differently about
that and now I've lost half a stone in
the last two weeks and I'm gonna keep
that up so what are you swapping in your
life and what could you adjust because
hating anything is how you do everything
lesson 4 nobody is self-made all those
four singer said I am NOT a self-made
millionaire I am NOT a self-made success
because no one's self-made I'm here
today because of the support and the
opportunities that people have put in
front of me
Wow why humbling challenge because
Arnold Schwarzenegger he grew up in
Austria with the same opportunities as
anyone else from Austria really yeah he
is this massive mega super successful
celebrity and he says I'm not self-made
and he went on to list all the people
that had inspired him and helped him and
supported him to get to areas today and
I thought that was just so humbling and
it will be so easy for shorts thinker to
say I grew up with nothing to know this
is where I am and I've done this and
I've done that but that's not how he
talks he's successful but he puts that
towards the other people who've
supported him so let that be a challenge
to you if you're successful already just
remember that Arnold Schwarzenegger says
no one is self-made of course you need
to take the opportunities that people
give you but don't get too big feed
boots because it's not a good looked it
won't serve you or anybody around you
lesson 5 invest in property why do I say
that because Arnold Schwarzenegger above
all things is foremost a property
investor in fact he became financially
free through real estate buying selling
renting out houses and then when he
became financially free he says himself
that then gave him the time to become a
movie star and really push and go hard
for becoming an actor if it wasn't for
property he wouldn't be an actor
most likely what a fantastic lesson so
you're probably watching this channel
because you're interested in property or
you're already an investor be encouraged
because property is the number one
vehicle to bringing financial freedom
and security into your life
which will ultimately lead to a whole
lot of fun and happiness
so in conclusion make success a habit
don't take yourself seriously but take
what you do seriously remember how you
do anything is how you do everything so
be disciplined in all of your areas of
your life and don't think you have to
choose health success happiness
relationships you can have them all
isn't it great get into property because
that will make you financially free and
then you'll go out to have the time to
do all the things you love and to
fulfill all of your dreams and lastly
stay humble and never think you're
better than anybody but remember nobody
is better than you so I hope you found
that video useful inspirational and
helpful for more videos like this please
don't forget to subscribe right here
below and I look forward to seeing you
very soon
[Music]